okay
you'll go from there
you have to get your mind
in my space and behind
so
the
initiates but you match do you see
so i should be here waiting for you and
you shouldn't go first okay
it's together
okay
so we'll switch roles so i can show you
this side okay so he's going to initiate
and i know that i want my right foot in
the cut
on the other one it was the other side
okay
you're using your kinesthetic awareness
to find my
when i'm in this stance
the cut hasn't finished so don't be in
your final on me with your hip turn
that's down here
you're either transitional in this
embryonic drill you got it okay
so
[Music]
don't look at the target keep medscan on
the upper thoracic cavity
down up here here
okay let's try this
so you see how we
match there you see so already there is
a communion he goes
okay and you want to keep that
throughout the entire drill
okay got it
so my pace doesn't change
okay so an example
that's not it that's not my because my
is space and time okay
and then i have the
template of the form that i have to do
and that is going to give me
my
ritualized
space i have to do the form in the
ritualized space so we're going to pass
through saigon okay
we're going to pass through
that point we're going to feel each
other's weapons okay
so i'm not going to go beforehand
and i'm not going to wait till i went
too deep
and i'm not going to not make contact
okay
that's my ritual template
so i gotta find my face time in that
movement okay
and his story goes up my sword goes up
because i'm matching his time you see
it's not his dead mind it's when his
goes up mind yourself
that's what i'm trying to work on
okay let's put it together go
i will stay with the cutting roll and i
want to show you some beginner mistakes
in the mod
because they're not safe so in order for
us to go on to this embryonic drill
number two
it has to be done safely okay
so
i'll give you some
some of the mistakes
reasons why you're making the mistakes
and some reference points to help you
not make
okay so we're going
you come in
and you're over aggressive
you see
and you're too close now the cutting not
[Music]
by trying available get on that guy
instead of staying and keeping him in
pugilistic range it happens all the time
it's also to think about it differently
it's a violation of just knife fighting
what's the closest target that's the one
you should hit for because it's the
least amount of risk well that means
stay back as much as you can there it is
right there this is the opposite okay
you want to be able to whack and you're
out again okay got it not in here just
trying to grapple
all right
um
so
the reference point
your hands will hit
the 90 with your shoulders
you see where my hands are with my
shoulders do you see that okay and
you'll see that yep he's in that cutting
portion of the blade if you start
changing things for example my hands are
too low
you weren't going to be too close or you
were going to miss okay you got that
uh
so
have this cut
boom your hands will stop
at shoulder height don't go any lower
okay you're going to get too close or
otherwise you're going to
keep your hands here you were too close
that's obvious but
a lot of you will think that's a good
that's a good correction it's not a good
question because i am too close as he
goes on to the technique do you see okay
so
uh understand why you're doing it do not
over regress stay back as far as you can
don't over commit in a knife fight
he goes home
stay out as far as you can and this has
to hit with my hands
and uh alignment with my shoulder height
okay all right let's try it again
we want to keep our nose back
away from the yo
go
so now we can do
embryonic drill number two we add
embryonic drill number one to the ending
of what you just did okay
you're gonna do the cut
so still staccato
he matches me
okay let's try in the ritual i create
the opening okay because there's no
opening at sega
that that's what you want okay i don't
want to create the opening before saigon
because
then uh he he will have the initiative
do you get that no you go to no opening
then i bait him
you see that okay so
uh listen to make sure you understand
that point boom i'm going and if we stop
it say god
it's neutral
do you get it so we're going to pass
through that neutrality
and then
i'm going to bake him
by taking my sword first away from sega
do you get it
um he feels that connection
and up and he takes it
okay if you look at yin and yang
he's following my sword going up and so
he goes up and attacks in that open
space this is very much like equal right
his shoulder is going up and that's when
my sword goes up it's not he's coming
down and and i catch his weapon his
weapon goes up and i catch his weapon
okay so you need that
timing
my sword goes up his sword goes up with
mine and then fills that void from the
in space but
it's my strategy
to give him that opening okay
um
so here's the thing
my is time space yes
yes my is time space but the application
of my
is not an intellectual understanding of
time space okay
it is a
a much deeper intuitive level
of
time space okay so at the beginning
when we're here
[Music]
we're already in communion we are all
although we're not touching
there is an eye key happening
do you understand and that is what we
are carrying on here online people i d
id id
stop
whoa
do you got it i don't i don't just walk
at him
i'm not just walking at him
the same feeling
uh i don't know do whatever
yeah the same feeling that i have uh uh
the releasing the opening you get it uh
the reconciling of his energy
uh that allows for that adhesion
the same
psychophysiological
mechanics that allows for that
he has this sword
it's there
same exact thing
do you understand well of course it has
to be because i don't i can't hear with
the tactile friction with the divine
do you understand and yet he is about
divine communion
you have the backwards
this divine communion here
is what is allowing for the adhesion
there
okay
so the worst thing you can do
is everything that you do that won't
allow you to adhere
are you afraid
is your mind traveling forward
do you have an egocentric
um an egocentricity to your movement
have you released have you released have
you released
do you get it and then
all that will happen
is once our swords touch you'll feel the
friction
and you take it off
okay
but
you still have the other one the
non-tactile connection okay
because when we go full speed
you're not touching anything
it's all this other non-tactile like
okay
so you must prove release this is not
you see this i'm never gonna do it
i'm terrified my body is terrified okay
if this part reminds me of uh tecumseh's
poem
remember his poem
say sing your
warrior song proudly and go
on your day of death
bravely do you get it you you gotta let
go you gotta let go
okay
boom same releasing
same exact psycho physiological feeling
cool and the same thing here i
i'm not doing that that's that same fear
response right from here i gotta
adhere to this weapon
and reach his center without touching
his center
you see it's the same thing
same connection
it's starting to go off off i can take
it off
i'll put it back on
it's very ritualistic okay
let's try it again
so
how to do how to do the ritual not not
what is the ritual how to do the ritual
okay
uh
it's very much there's like a zazen
aspect to it
okay my gaze is in that skin
and my what doesn't need to move does
not move
do you understand that so there's a kind
of stillness to it
do you understand okay
uh and there's also a kind of the same
kind of at least the
mindfulness right if not
uh hopefully some sort of fudoshi
you're just letting your mind open open
okay
but your mind will not open if your body
is all
in this world
okay
so here you are you're trying to do the
no
your stance is all over the place man
let you let the energy of your mass
flow through you you see right away this
is a different body
this one
you don't realize you're doing it but
you're moving all over the place you
look like crackheads
okay
it's meditative okay so
stop everything stops my gaze is not
really my eyes that you see with
normally
okay
like i'm not really looking at him i see
him but i'm not looking at him do you
understand
it's in this kind of open space open
releasing just like in zazen
disconnecting my consciousness from my
worldly senses okay
feeling instead the energy of everything
going through the same rituals through
your body down to your midfoot release
relax
yourself moving moving moving moving
moving
same thing no added tension
release relax relief do you understand
and no no extraneous movement in my body
no extraneous movement i can sit here
all day we'll sit here all day and do
the same technique okay then my turn to
go and all i do is what i'm supposed to
do
got it not done
and then let it settle
let all of that coke you
pull on emanate from your person outward
till you feel it gone
then regain center
back
same thing not
okay again
uh
if you want out
get on the other side of the mat
and take your break
but in the move
in the ritual a kind of moving stillness
okay try it again